the two most
important data governance roles are data
owners and data stewards but there are
other roles
when asked who has responsibility for
data governance in an organization
the answer must be everyone much like
requiring staff to agree to a code of
ethics
or adhere to particular values if an
organization employs data governance
the expectation must be that all staff
agree to support the function of data
governance
what other roles have particular
importance regarding data governance
there are a range of technology roles
such as a database administrator
or a software developer both of which
for example
manage many aspects of creating reading
updating and deleting data
they may have special requirements
relative to data governance
such as adherence to industry
regulations
we know for example that everyone who
handles healthcare data must follow
specific data handling rules
like what can be stored and who can
access it
other roles include attorneys who advise
data owners and stewards about data
requirements
such as privacy or disclosure there are
auditors who are tasked with
making sure that all of the
organization's data is being handled in
accordance with policies
and there's security professionals who
identify vulnerabilities to the data
security and confidentiality
and make sure that all data is being
kept out of reach of those individuals
both inside and outside the organization
who shouldn't have
access to it there are also those people
who capture and input data
for example sales clerks who handle
credit cards and might have access to
customers contact information
or telephone support agents who are
working with your customers to resolve
any questions or issues they may have
when thinking about these roles you must
think about the following questions
are each of these roles sufficiently
trained
what can be done to reduce data entry
errors and maintain high quality
finally there's a critical role for
management all levels of management must
help to communicate value
and support enforcement if data
governance is not supported
and messaging from management isn't
clear or inconsistent it will be less
successful
you